Thank you Ben, thank you everyone for joining
me here today, it's a real honour, thank you
JSConf for making this happening, as Ben said
I'll talk about visualising the application,
the code just being a part of it, as we all
know apps are so much more than code. So,
we'll see whether we can use some 3D visualisation
techniques to get a better perspective of
our apps.
So we'll use this as the a case study, the
awesome to do app, we have maybe created a
version of this app, some of us may have contributed
to the project using different frameworks
to create a to do app, I think it will be
a good example that most of us can relate
to, just for those that may not be familiar,
so they understand what they are looking at,
it's a to do app, you put in to do items,
check them off, sort them, so you get different
views and that's essentially the functionality,
ok.
So, we ask, what's an app? The first thing
that comes to mind, it's code, looks something
like this, we're all intimately familiar with
this sort of view. In order to sort of maybe
better understand the reasoning why we need
to see things beyond just the code, not just
see them but share them, show them, we'll
look at a more tangible example, like coffee.
What's coffee? it's ingredients something
like this, very simple ingredients, water,
coffee beans, that's all. Now, go and tell
that to those people outsides pre-so coffee,
the beautiful folks from the Barn, are they
great, awesome .
Good job to JSConf for setting that up. You
see their set up, it's people, it's not just
ingredients, we have a person taking the order,
a person making the coffee, tense of thousands
of dollars of equipment, that Espresso machine,
$5,000, I know, I used to have a coffee shop,
the coffee we take for
granted, we got a much better perspective
when we think about it in a 3D way, we have
a sense of geography, if the coffee shop is
in Baltimore and we're here in Berlin that's
no good for us, all these things come into
play when we want to think more broadly about
where our coffee comes from, what our coffee
really is.
The key message here, sort of a no brainer,
coffee shop is a much bigger deal than the
coffee itself, we are using the to do list
app as a case study, it's a much bigger deal
than a to do list or a feature, the to do
app is a much bigger deal than the feature
set that is designed.
When we put the 3D view up of the coffee shop
we are able to get perspective on the scale
of the coffee shop, location of it, able to
see the people, processes, things, in that
traceability, the concrete artefacts, the
coffee machine, the location of the bathrooms
in respect to the entrance, the concrete things
give us a good appreciation for what's involved,
everybody understands that 3D diagram, whether
you are a coffee farmer, coffee maker, a business
owner, customer, we all intuitively understand
that.
So what's what we are hoping for in our 3D
application view. So we have on the left hand
side the coffee shop, the inputs into that
visualisation are things like the ingredients,
inventory, people and infrastructure and we
have the output the analogous input for the
to do list, will be the code, support scripts,
our people very important and our infrastructure,
somehow we are going to come up with the 3D
diagram, that's hopefully what we will get
to together today, I'll do some of your audience
participation, I can see this far in to the
conference, people are a little more tired.
So we start with the code, so we start out
with the app as code text, now we are getting
to something beyond the text, the files, the
folders, the file system, so already, there
is a little bit more to our code than just
the text file. Here we just have a subtle
benefit of the 3D view, just the beginnings
of 3D visualisation in terms of getting a
better perspective.
Here, for example, we can see the entire folder
structure, the sort of thing you would to
click through every single folder to see how
deep they are, in one view if we do this sort
of leverage, the third dimension, we can see
the top level folders, contains of a assets
folder, Java assets folder and so on, across
the whole code base.
So maybe somebody there. So another way we
can gain some value, looking at things in
3D, if we juxtaposition the files next to
the diagram, we have a visual way, quickly,
shorthand, to see what files are important,
visually you can see the file in front, this
file has less code than the one behind it,
it gives you a little bit of overview, perspective,
shorthand perspective if you will. Obviously
you need a lot more, just to look at the file
system in 3D may not be directly a huge amount
of value for that. To explore further, let's
compare with a more complex app, so we introduce
discourse, another great open sources app
that folks made available, some of the folks
behind stack overflow, it's a forum software
so people interact, write blog
messages, post comments, there is some mail
and bulletin board functionality, it's a very
complex app. So, while I have two open sources
apps, someone mentioned open sources just
before I got up, give a quick round of applause
to people who contribute to open sources .
Awesome.
So, what can we see in 3D, we can see a relative
size of things and now, one thing we see is
that all discourse is much bigger, we put
it next to a model there, let's say someone
in the room I sat next to from Korea, studying
in Finland I just met today, manager of our
team, standing next to the code base modelled
in certain dimensions, she gets to say look
at how big my code base is, so, at the same
time she can also share that with err management,
by saying hey, look how big my code base is!
We saw a talk on Friday, Kai from Microsoft,
talked about the changes in the new Microsoft
browsers compare to EI, talked about lines
of code, we all need statistics like that
for different reasons here's another way to
show the relative size of things while looking
at the actual file systems, and to give perspectives
to folks at a glance view, hey that's a big
app, that's life size, well not life size,
that is to scale, the Airbus A 380, is to
scale, that's just the JavaScript portion
of the discourse apps. So again there is some
value in showing things that way, both for
us as developers, technologists but also for
business partner, I think that should help
our partners in understanding what we do.
So, what else can we see? Can we gain any
insight about the structure of are code, beyond
ok it's a big code base, first to do that
let's look at the folders of the code, let's
ignore the files for a second, that allows
a more compact view, that's what we see here
at the first shot of things.
Now let's sort things, let's sort them with
the advantage of a 3D perspective, so let's
use x , y , z planes, we can sort in one direction
on one folder level, another sort in another
direction on the y plane for the next folder
level, we are using the advantage of all our
planes a little bit, it gives a more compact
code base, so now that code base that was
the length of the A 380 that had no hope whatsoever
of fitting on the screen now we can see in
one compact view.
So what's the advantage of that? First of
all, I think that by itself is awesome, I
don't know how many of you have been clicking
through, being able to see the whole directory
system at once is awesome.
Now I say you can go directly to any file
at any level, another quick benefit of looking
at things in 3D, we can see patterns, it doesn't
really take an expert eye to say, this one
on the left, it's named, "Admin", the top
level folder is named admin, this one is,
"Discourse", they are fatter, longer, it looks
like the folders have names, models, folders,
components, maybe they are the two men apps
in the whole apps, these are some of the patterns
we want to see when we are exploring a code
base, now we can see in 3D rather quickly
and also non-technical people might also be
able to get it, maybe an appreciation of that
without understanding the code base so much.
Of course, now we need to see the files, so
if we want to explore any folder, we can click
any of them or all of them at one time, again
sufficient of the limitation of the current
methods of viewing our folder structure, either
using the command line or the operating system
GUI, had limitation of seeing one folder one
directory at the time or it clunky when you
want to see more.
So that's all 3D code, but Ola you said, app
is not just code you just spent the last 10
minutes talking about code ok, so we have
a computer, we start off with the code but
now we're introduce our run time. We have
to put the computer into the picture in this
case we can see in one view that we have a
certain code pace it runs on windows operating
system, it actually needs a browser as a reason
time, and so again shorthand view of what
our getting better perspective on what our
app looks like in a shorthand.
We also need a user, another thing that I
missing in a lot of diagram either with oversimplifying
the stick figure user or non-existent at all
let's have the user in the view, some app
or software don't need a user perhaps they
interact with environment or sensors or other
apps but we're talking the webapp, there a
user involved let's show them. Now we're talking
in this particular room about a special type
of app software called webapp, so we need
a web server here, that we introduce new men
that platform there the server the node express
has NDN dependency it serves HTTP in this
case on the same computer. That looks like
our developers machine, clearly it's still
not what an app looks like really in the wild,
but we're getting there slowly so now we introduce
developer and developer want developer tools
that go with that, and now we can also show
and share perhaps succinctly but certainly
in a way that developer does more than code.
Clearly there's the build, there's test and
there are tools that go with that against
some more dependencies, more installation
shown in orange, you just very familiar with
Git, it was mentioned in the talk before mine,
others have talked about the transpiling tool,
Peter Muller did a great talk on Friday I
recommend anyone who didn’t see that to
check out video, talking about a different
language transpiling tools we have to deal
with and perhaps a better way to do that.
Here we can visualise that among the other
tools that we used.
So here's our view about our developer, some
perspective are the kinds of things you see
at a glance when you look at a system, or
an application, in particular development
environment this way. We can do a technology
comparison. Here we say oh, another stack
we could use for our webapp is ember and ember
as a facility called ember that include some
of the same installation, those separate installs
we had to do for transpiling or testing the
build dependency management it's all in ember
so we can do a visual comparison, it doesn't
tell you which one is better or worse just
give you some perspective if you saw one developers
machine in this view of another developers
machine in that view you can see the difference
rather quickly, and in the stacks they use
and why how these stacks are different.
Same things with rails, rails are totally
different technology from our JavaScript frameworks,
server side framework we can still visualise
the developer environment. So here just trying
to show the versatility of looking at things
in $3 how it's not just for this specific
type of app I think almost any code pace any
type of app can benefit from this kind visualisation.
What happened to our user is way over there
or over there. No code for the user, poor
user. So what do we have to do, we have to
do some deployment stabs which is more tools
and more roles for our development team in
this case our single developer, by the way
I wish I should name my developer I will name
her Sandra, someone I met here today from
Zimbabwe very great effort from JSConf
so there's Sandra, now she has to deploy our
code, more tools we might have FTP file programme,
to transport the tools, we might use Amazon
S3 for our storage. The simplest way you can
deploy a single page app, so we do that, we
deploy Amazon S3 we have to configure some
DNS so the domain names work out right, today
spoke a little bit about some of the issues
that come up with DNS routing and so forth.
Whatever we can figure in S 3 in Amazon the
default routes, error messages, error screens
they are code they make up our system, they
are part of thing that just totally get lost
whenever we either point to our code and say
hey the code is the app, or when we try to
do a little bit better than that and we draw
the diagram of the app here's our S3 cloud,
here’s a client and server, instead of the
2 dimensional ways we do. I think that shorthand
is great it's awesome for us as engineers
but I think the value of getting a little
bit more sophisticated is very beneficial
for I think for us as engineers, but also
for our partners, clients, bosses, we deploy
everything we should, ask are we done. Things
are working, app has been developed, user
can download it, make their to do list, but
as it generally goes we need more features
we need more developers so Sandra needs a
partner, co-worker. We introduced another
developer with another development environment
we model their develop environment there's
might not be Mac, but for the sake of this
talk, we have just said it the same sort of
set up. So we bring in Bryan who spoke a little
earlier from San Francisco all the way here
from San Francisco and what kind of development
team if we don't have someone from Silicon
Valley on the team, so Bryan is here collaborating
on the app. Now they have Github as a shared
repository, they use it shared repository,
they are both doing there separate build deploy
test, how long is I before a different operating
system, a different configuration on one person's
machine makes it past here or failed there,
so we need to have a shared build and test
environment, that's what we have done we have
create up here in this case we have used Amazon
c2 as a cloud structure, we have a Linux operating
system we can see visually that's different
from our Mac. Again some of those sort of
things that make up our system very important
things that make up our system that I think
often get lost way too easily when we talk
about our systems.
So we got more tools more code configuration
but when ask are we done, some of you are
already looking at that gap the gulf between
the dev and the prod, something is missing
you might also be looking saying this dev
part looks a whole lot different from prod.
My development environment is not made up
of S3 I can't have that on my machine that's
why we have what we
have. Similarly S3 does not support build
tool we have set up using our EC2 instance.
These things are so different. Maybe we need
something else, introduce staging environment.
Try to make that identical to production,
we have someone playing that role, of testing
our pre-production app in staging let's called
that person today as we could see in his presentation
he is anal about quality and errors if anyone
can catch any errors before going to production
it today. He has some tools to catch any ringers
production it would be a good candidate for
us to GA before we get to production.
So are we done? Cloud storage we didn't talk
about that we're all using local storage we
need some code for the database, we need sub
database actual executable database app installation,
so we have shown that there in red, now we
have got to upgrade our staging. We go from
S3 to EC do again I think the value of the
3D visualisation is that you know just visually
you look at the S3 versus the EC2 you can
see that it's different and you can see it's
significantly different and crucially our
team mates can see that we as a team and our
partners, clients, customers, executives.
So when we said yeah you know it's going to
take some more resources it going to take
some more time for us to go from S3 to EC2
they have a way to visualise this, they don't
have Java to think that oh whatever magic
you guys do just do it faster. I mean you
drew S3 as a circle, so make it so, but now
we can give them a better perspective, for
what's involved. So with that, again you can
ask the question, are we done? Valid question
but I think you are seeing the pattern now
right? The pattern is really we're never done
right? I mean that's sort of the reality of
our lives. They are all these things that
have I have not touched honestly that part
of are daily lives different infrastructure,
operational things we need to introduce we
talk about containerisation now instead of
virtual machine infrastructure, we might use
in memory data stores like memcache, a whole
bunch of stuff we can do on the infrastructure
side, same thing we have services we generally
need to plug-in here, message queues, workflow
energy other kinds of storage, we may introduce
different communication pathways using web
socket or peer to peer or streaming some great
talks about that earlier. I recommend Thomas's
yesterday evening talking about streaming
it peer to peer which you should check out
if you missed it yesterday or Friday.
So, I think the 3D view helps us visualise
better all these aspects of our system. So,
hopefully at this point we have some analogous
way of looking at our app as a system, including
people including processes, including assets
and resources similarly to how we might think
of the physical thing like a coffee shop,
physical system like a coffee shop I beg your
pardon. Me see the same in sight we can have
the perspective of the location and scale
of our application, we can see the people,
the processes, the things as well as have
traceability to concrete artefacts, this is
intuitively understood.
So, talk a little bit about the tools I am
sure many of you are wondering how do you
do, what's he showing me. In this case what
you are seeing here today uses Ruby as a scripting
language, integrating with Github I will talk
about the integrations I have done over so
far and a 3D modelling talk called Sketchup.
I have done produced similar results using
Javascript JS
library as well as JavaScript and another
modelling software called tinker cat I can
talk you to off line all about why I am not
using those now, I am still evaluating they
might be something I will end up doing more
with.
Then we talk about API integrations, currently
Github is the anyone, the source code you
saw there from discuss or to do, this is based
on the code base of those apps from Github,
through using the Ruby scripts, using ruby
and the Sketchup modelling tool I created
the visualisation of the app code pace. Very
interesting future work for me and others
interested in this kind of field will be to
integrate whatever modelling tools they come
up with and I want to do it with this, other
source control systems, you see there other
cloud platforms would be great to directly
integrate to cloud bottom,, query Amazon and
Azure and for the status of our applications,
the size of them, the configuration of them
the show those in our visualisation. Similarly
it would be great to integrate with the various
CI and devtools that are out there some of
you are familiar with. Still along the lines
of future exploration I am working on getting
this stuff open sourced. It's not right now,
I can't give you a URL get the modelling tool
I will be adding more components, you saw
JavaScript biased with infrastructure, the
same things apply for any infrastructure or
development tools you use Java, or whatever
have you, ruby. What will be really awesome
would be to integrate with the various 3D
interaction technologies, Google cardboard,
Microsoft lens, Occulus I am not there yet.
Would be great. Some of you my motivation
for that some of you guys know the code really
hard to find it that attributed to that which
measures improved, to that I add which is
visualised, improved even if we're not empirically
and quantitatively measuring something, just
being able to visualise it being able to see
symmetry see patterns, see some degree of
complexity is not the final word on how complex
all kinds of visualised, the fact that everybody
can't thank you to you guys have been great
thank you very much. So why are these false.
I could really use your feedback as I said,
either on some of the current stuff you see
or some of the future interactions you can
help with or you are doing yourself, I would
love to hear about it,, so, thank you, thank
you to Berlin, the Berlin people, you have
been super awesome, you guys have been great,
. .